[موسيقى]
الحصاد معكم جلال شهده في الوقت الذي
احدثكم فيه احداث تقع وتتفاعل اخرى
البدايه من مقاطعه الروسيه التي تقول
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها شهدت تضرر بونا
تحتيه وسكنيه مع تجدد للقصف الاوكراني على
ثلاث مناطق حدوديه في المقاطعه
من جنوب الخرطوم نتابع هذه الصور المباشره
غدا انتهاء الهدنه بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع بالتزامن مع دعوه
امريكيه سعوديه لوقف جديد لاطلاق النار
ومن برشتينا تاتينا هذه الصور المباشره
وسط مخاوف من تفاقم الاوضاع في شمال
كوسوفو بعد تعرض قوات النيتو لهجمات من
متظاهرين الصرب
في موضع الحصاد
[موسيقى]
مع توسع الهجمات في الداخل الروسي موسكو
تعلنو افشال محاوله عبور اوكرانيه الى
بلغرود وحكموا المقاطعه يقول انه مستعد
للتفاوض مع مسلحين يحتجزون جنودا واكياف
تعتبر الهجمات في بيل جرو الدليلا على
نهايه عصر استقرار بوتين
مع انتهاء الهدنه المعارك تشتد في العاصمه
السودانيه الجيش يقول انه استعاد قاعده
النجوم الجويه جنوب الخرطوم ودعوه سعوديه
امريكيه للطرفين الى التوصل لاتفاق جديد
على وقف لاطلاق النار وتنفيذه بشكل فعال
في خضم توتر امريكي صيني متصاعد يقول ان
السفينه حربيه صينيه اجت مناوره غير امنه
قرب مدمره امريكيه في مضيق تايوان بجين
تقول ان التوحيد الصين امر حتمي وانها لن
تتسامح مع اي محاوله لفص تايوان وتحذر من
اقامه التحالفات عسكريه شبيهه في محيطها
ووفد امريكي رفيع يصل الصين لبحث قضايا
حقوق الانسان والحريات
لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
تتابعون في الحصاد ايضا اتفاق دول اوبك
بلاس على خفض الانتاج للعام القادم بمقدار
مليون و400 الف برميل يوميا وروسيا
والسعوديه وعمان والامارات والكويت
والعراق والجزائر يعلنون تمديد التخفيض
الطاوعي حتى نهايه 2004
[موسيقى]
البدايه بالهجمات المتلاحقه على مناطق
داخل روسيا اذ اعلنت وزاره دفاع روسيه
افشال محاوله عبور مجموعه اوكرانيه باتجاه
مقاطعه
واكد حاكم المقاطعه فياتي
عن استعداده لمقابله المسلحين الذين
اعلنوا اسرى جنديين روسيين لمناقشه عمليه
تبادلهم جانبه قال مستشار رئاسه
الاوكرانيه ميخايلو بودولاك ان المعارك في
بيل جرود تشكل نهايه عصر استقرار بوتين
بحسب تعبيره
حدود طويله وشائكه تحكمها الجغرافيا
السياسيه والتاريخ فعلى قرابه 2200 كم
تمتد الحدود بين روسيا واوكرانيا قبل
الحرب
تغيرت الحدود الجغرافيه بفعل القتال فخسرت
اوكرانيا القرمه ومساحات من اقليم
دومباسون لكنها نجحت بتحويل حدود ضيقه مع
مقاطعه روسيه واحده الى جبهه شبه متكافئه
هذه بالكرات الروسيه
تقابلها الاوكرانيه
وخط الحدود هذا تسللت منه مجموعات تقول
انها روسيه معارضه لسياسه موسكو لتشعل بعض
النقاط في المقاطعه وتاخذ
رهائن من جنود الروس وتوجه رساله لحاكم
المقاطعه تدعوه للتفاوض
[موسيقى]
نحن على استعداد لمنحك هؤلاء الاسرى من
الجنود الروس لاتاحه الفرصه للتواصل معك
شخصيا ومناقشه الوضع الحالي في المنطقه
الاهم الحديث عن مستقبلها ومستقبل روسيا
بشكل عام وعن الحرب الدمويه غير الضروريه
منذ عام ونصف وهي الان تجري على اراضي
منطقه الخاصه بك
[موسيقى]
حدد المتحدث باسم ما يسمى فيلق المتطوعين
الروس كنيسه في بلده تشيبي كينو الروسيه
مكانا للتفاوض وقبل حاكم المقاطعه ما يفسر
اعترافا من السلطات المحليه الروسيه بان
المجموعه لديها وجود ميداني في المقاطعه
وسيطره على بعض مناطقها ايضا ليست بالجراد
وحدها التي تستهدف بقصف او هجمات وتوغل
بري كورس كالمجاوره وفيرانسك ايضا
احدى عشره منطقه حدوديه تعرضت وتتعرض
للاستهداف
استهدافات تتهم موسكو كييف بالوقوف خلفها
كييف تنفي بينما تتبنى مجموعات تقول انها
مناهضه لموسكو المسؤوليه احيانا وبينما
يستمر الرئيس الروسي بالتحذير من خطوره
التلاعب بالاستقرار داخل روسيا تؤكد كييف
وجاهه مخاوف بوتين فيقول مستشار الرئاسه
ميخايل قدولياك انها نهايه عصره
[موسيقى]
من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي اللواء الدويري
انطلاقا من
هجماته حتى الان ما حجم القلق الذي يشكله
ما يعرف بفيلق حريه روسيا بالنسبه للرئيس
بوتين للقوات الروسيه
لا يعني هو اصبح تحدي واضح لانه نفذ
العديد من العمليات هذه ليست العمليه
الاولى
ونلاحظ من خلال المتابعه ان عملياته تزداد
جراه وخطوره وان هناك اخفاقات من قبل حرس
الحدود المسؤول عن تامين هذه الحدود ما
بين بالقرود وخاركيف والان الحديث عن
مفاوضات داخل كنيسه داخل
الاراضي الروسيه اذا هناك يبدو اصبح نوع
من التجذر لهذه القوات ونوع من الانتشار
واصبحوا لا اقول رقما صعبا لكن رقما مزعجا
للامن والاستقرار داخل بالقرود طيب كيف
نفهم هذا روسيا التي تقول بانها تسيطر على
ثلث مساحه اوكرانيا وتقاتل في العمق
الاوكراني ياتيها هذا الامر في عمقها كيف
نفهم هذا
يعني هذا حتى اجيبك لابد ان امر
بعجاله الجيش الروسي خسر فيكيف خسر في خير
كيف خسر في زبروجيا ولم ينجح في سوليدار
وفاخموت استعان بقوات فاغنر ومن ثم
ظهر قائد قوات فاجنر يتحدث عن خطوره الوضع
في بيل جرود وقال قد نذهب الى تلك المنطقه
الاستعاده الامن وتامين المواطنين دون
الرجوع والطلب من جهه اخرى وهنا يقصد
وزاره الدفاع ووزير الدفاع شويجو هذا قد
يكون له مارب الشخصيه في هذا التصريح
ولكنه يجسد الواقع في تلك المنطقه المشكله
بدات بصوره جاده منذ الهجوم على الكرملين
منذ تلك اللحظه
انتقلت الحرب الى صوره في البدايه كانت هي
عباره عن
القتال البري التقليدي واستخدام القصف
الصاروخي لا اصبح المعنى الدقيق للعمليات
العسكريه اطلق عليه الحرب الهجينه من جانب
القوات الاوكرانيه لان لديها اكثر من
مقاربه عسكريه في نفس الوقت هناك قتال
داخل المناطق المحتله في كييف هناك عمليات
القصف بالطائرات المسيره
ومهاجمه مناطق متعدده وصلت الى ماريوبل
والى حدود
موسكو وهناك
التنظيمات شبه العسكريه هي التي بدات
مزعجه وبدات تقدم شيء يسبب الارباك
للقياده على الاقل في محيط منطقه بلغرود
طيب القياده الاوكرانيه يبدو انها تراهن
الان على هذه المجموعه التي تقاتل في في
الى اي مدى ممكن ان تؤثر هذه المجموعه على
سير المعارك في الجبهات المحتدمه داخل
اوكرانيا
يعني اعتقد ان الرهان مبالغ فيه من وجهه
نظر عسكريه هذه المجموعات التي تقادر سواء
فيلق حريه روسيا او فيلق المتطوعين الروس
جماعات صغيره لا تستطيع ان تلقي بتاثير
واضح جدا على اداره المعارك في مناطق اخرى
هذه حتى هذه اللحظه مسؤوليه المواجهه تعود
الى حرس الحدود الروسي والى
مسؤوليه محافظه بالقرود ولم يتم بالحديث
عن ارسال قوات روسيه لتمسك بزمام الامور
مما يؤثر على سير المعارك شكرا فتم طرح
الورقه البديله ان قوات فاجنر هي من
ستتكفل بالمعالجه شكرا لك اللواء فايزه
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي في عمان
الاردن
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات في السودان في اول يوم بعد
انتهاء هدنه الايام الخمسه فقد افاد مصدر
بالجيش السوداني للجزيره ان الجيش استعاد
السيطره على قاعده النجوم الجويه جنوب
الخرطوم والتي كانت تحت سيطره قوه الدعم
السريع منذ بدايه المعارك هذا وافاد مراسل
الجزيره في الخرطوم ان طائرات حربيه تابعه
للجيش السوداني استهدفت تجمعات لقوات
الدعم السريع بمنطقه الجريف شرقي الخرطوم
وفي اقليم دارفور نفى المتحدث باسم الجيش
السوداني نبيل عبد الله للجزيره ما تردد
من انباء عن سقوط مدينه كوتم بولايه شمال
دارفور في ايدي من وصفهم بالمتمردين واتهم
عبد الله قوات الدعم السريع بمهاجمه
المدينه واكد تصدي الجيش لها ياتي ذلك
بالتوازي مع تواتر انباء عن وجود معارك
عنيفه بين الطرفين هناك
المملكه العربيه السعوديه والولايات
المتحده الجيش السوداني وقوه الدعم السريع
الى التوصل الى اتفاق على وقف لاطلاق
النار جديد
وتنفيذه بشكل فعال بهدف بناء وقف دائم
للعمليات العسكريه وقال بيانو لوزاره
الخارجيه السعوديه ان الرياض و واشنطن
حريصتان على استمرار المحادثات مع وفدي
التفاوض السودانيين وقالت الخارجيه في
بيان ان السعوديه والولايات المتحده على
استعداد لاستئناف المحادثات الرسميه
السودانيه مشيره الى ان وفدي الجيش والدعم
السريع لا يزالان موجودين في جده رغم
تعليق المحادثات وانتهاء وقف النار
وكان بيان الخارجيه السعوديه قال ان على
طرفي الصراع على التزام باعلان جده وحمايه
المدنيين في السودان
في هذه الاثناء قال قائد القوات الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان دقلو انه ناقش مع وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه هاتفيا الاوضاع
بالسودان في ظل الجهود المبذوله من
الوساطه السعوديه الامريكيه واكد دجالو
لوزير الخارجيه السعوديه التزام قوته
باعلان حمايه المدنيين ومواصله العمل على
تسهيل ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه كما رحب
بالبيان المشترك الذي اعلنت عنه الوساطه
اليوم حول استمرار المباحثات غير المباشره
ينضم الينا من واشنطن الدكتور كاميرون
هاتسون مستشار المبعوثه الامريكي السابق
الى السودان ومسؤول شؤون افريقيا السابق
في البيت الابيض دكتور في اي سياق تضع هذه
الدعوه من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والسعوديه للتفاوض من جديد في وقت علقت
فيه مشاركه الجيش السوداني في مفاوضات
سابقه وتحتدم المعارك على الارض
يبدو ان هناك الكثير من الامل
برؤيه محادثات فعليه او احرز اي تقدم
صحيح ان الطرفين قد حافظ على عدد قليل من
الممثلين لهم في جده
ينزلون في فندق فخم
ولكن ربما بوجودهما او بوجودهم ربما يظهر
ان الموضوع شديد ولكن نحن وصلنا الان الى
مرحله لم يعد فيها الكلام ينفع يجب ان نرى
تغييرات على الارض
ان نرى طرفا طرفين يتوقف عن العمليات هذا
لا لن يحصل الا اذا ارى احد الطرفين اي
تقدم تكتيكي نراهما يحاولان لتحقيق تقدم
تكتيكي من خلال الاتيان بقوات جديده
والاستمرار في هذا الاعتداء تعتقد سنر
المزيد من القتال وحتى سيصير اسوا في
الاسابيع الاشهر المقبله طيب ايضا كيف
نفهم هذه الدعوه الامريكيه للع
وده للمحادثات وقفه اطلاق النار في وقت
قررت الولايات المتحده واداره الرئيس
بايدن فرض عقوبات على طرفي النزاع
ووعدهم
انا لا اعتقد ان هذه خطوات غير منطقيه حين
تستخدم العقوبات طريقه جيده كما حصل من
قبل هي اداه لحمل الاطراف على الكلام ما
يجب ان يطالب به الطرفان او ان يغنى هو ما
يجب القيام به لرفع العقوبات بعد فرضها
بمجرد ان الطرفين لا يبحثان في ذلك هذا
يعني ان العقوبات لم تؤثر بهما لم تضر
بهما لم تغير او لم تغير حساباتهما حول
المعارك وهذا دليل بان هذه العقوبات لم
تذهب الى حد تحفيز اي تغيير في سلوكيات اي
من الطرفين قلت بانك لا تتوقع
استجابه من الطرفين لهذه الدعوه وبانه
السودان سيشهد المزيد من العنف
والتوتر كيف سيكون موقف الاداره الامريكيه
في هذه الحاله
ايضا واضح ان هذا او ان هذه الاداره ليس
لديها اي تاثير كبير على طرفين هما
ملتزمان بالقتال يحظى يعني بدعم خارجي
اقوى تدعم السريع تاتي بالدعم ليبيا
والامارات بينما
الجيش السودانيه ياتي بقوات الدفاع
الشعبيه وغيرها من الميليشيات المساعده
اذا مع استمرار ذلك
ومع استقطاب المزيد من الاطراف الى هذا
النزاع سوف يكون اصعب بعد على واشنطن
والرياض واي اطراف اخرى ان تؤثر بعد اكثر
على طرفين ما يمكن لورشه ان تامله الان هو
احتواء هذا النزاع ايصالات الانسانيه وان
تمكن من يريد الهروب الهروب فعلا حفاظا
على سلامتها هذا افضل ما يمكننا ان نتامله
الان اذا الاجدب الولايات المتحده ان تضغط
على الاطراف التي تمول بالمال والسلاح
طرفين نزاع في السودان دكتور
انها الورقه الوحيده التي علينا ان نلعبها
الان تحاول واشنطن ان تعرقل التمويل
وتعرقل القدره على شراء الاسلحه
وسيراد المزيد من الاسلحه ودفع المزيد من
المقاتلين هذا قد يساعد من خلال العقوبات
على شركات ولكن اذا كانت قوات الدعم
السريع تحصل على دعم مدين ومالي من ابوظبي
او من قوه حفتر في ليبيا
كان ذلك لن يهم اذا كنا قد اوقفنا التمويل
لقوى الدعم السريع او للمؤسسات المرتبطه
بها او بالجيش اذا كانت المؤسسات من
الخارج تدعمهما اذا يجب ان يكون هناك
استراتيجيه دبلوماسيه بالاضافه الى
استراتيجيه عقوبات وحاليا لا يبدو ان
واشنطن لديه دبلوماسيه استراتيجيه
لمضي قدما لاحتواء الموضوع
اذا ابعاد الاطراف الخارجيه شكرا لك
الدكتور كاميرون
الامريكيه السابق الى السودان
[موسيقى]
قالت القياده الامريكيه في منطقه المحيطين
الهندي والهادئ ان سفينه حربيه صينيه قامت
بما وصفته بالمناوره غير الامنه قرب مدمره
امريكيه في مضيق تايوان يوم امس السبت
واوضحت القياده والنسفينه الصينيه اقتربت
من المدمر الامريكيه حتى صارت على بعد 140
مترا منها فقط وهو امر اجبر طاقم المدمره
الامريكيه على تخفيف السرعه فاديا
للاصطدام
اعتبرت القياده الامريكيه ان السفينه
الصينيه انتهكت قواعد العبور الامن في
المياه الدوليه
وكان البنتاجون قد ندد بيم اوصفه بتصرفات
الخطيره بشكل متزايد للجيش الصيني في اسيا
وقال المتحدث باسم البنتاجون في تصريحات
على هامش منتدى شانجريلا الذي اختتم اليوم
في سنغافوره ان بلاده ما زالت قلقه ازاء
مسماه الانشطه الخطره والاستفزازيه للجيش
الصيني في المنطقه بما في ذلك ما حصل في
الايام الاخيره بحسب تعبيره
في المقابل حذر وزير الدفاع الصيني
لشنكوفو من اقامه تحالفات عسكريه شبيهه
بالنيتو في منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ وفي
ختام منتدى حوار شانجريلا اضاف ان بيجين
لن تتسامح مع اي محاولات لفصل تايوان عن
الصين
في قلب الاهتمام او التنافس او الصراع
منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ تعود لواجهه
التصريحات العاكسه لتوترات صينيه امريكيه
في اول حديث له منذ توليه منصبه في مارس
الماضي يحذر وزير الدفاع الصيني من اقامه
تحالفات عسكريه شبيهه في المنطقه خلال
كلمه له في منتدى حوار الشانجريلا للامن
والدفاع الذي اختتم في سنغافوره
اقترحت بعض القوى الكبرى ما تسمى
باستراتيجيه المحيطين الهندي والهدء
وتعتقد الصين انه لا ينبغي لاي استراتيجيه
ان تبني تحالفات عسكريه اقصائيه قائمه على
الايديولوجيا وما يسمى بالتهديدات
المفترضه الوزير الصيني بدا يلمح صراحه
لتحالفات اقامتها الولايات المتحده في
المنطقه ابرزها التحالف اوكوس الذي يضم
استراليا والمملكه المتحده والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه واقيم في سبتمبر 2021
ضمن توجه من اداره بايدن يجعل اسيا منطقه
ذات اولويه قصوى على المستوى الاستراتيجي
تقول الاداره الامريكيه ان هدف التحالف
تعزيز التعاون وضبط الامن في المحيط
الهادئ لكن بيجين لا ترى فيه الا محاوله
لتطويقها استراتيجيا وعسكريا هناك ايضا
تحالف كواد واسمه الحوار الرباعي للامن
ويضم الولايات المتحده واليابان والهند
واستراليا واعلن قيامه عام 2007 اعيد
احيائه مع انتخاب بايدن حيث اجتمع قادته
في واشنطن اواخر عام 2021
في خضم هذه المخاوف فينا فوازير الدفاع
الامريكي بوقت سابق محاوله بلاده تشكيل اي
هيكل امني غربي جديد على غرار النيتو في
منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ لكن بالعوده
للوراء فقد اعلن نيتو خلال قمته في مدريد
عام 2002 ان الصين تمثل التحديا منهجيا
لمصالح دول الحلف وامنها وادرج هذا
التصنيف في وثيقه التفكير الاستراتيجي
للنيتو 2022
شهدت القمه حينها لاول مره حضور دول من
المحيطين الهادئ والهندي هي اليابان
واستراليا وكوريا الجنوبيه ونيوزيلندا
بصفه مراقب في الحلف وعكس ذلك ربطا للامن
الاوروبي بالامن الاسيوي وبدات اليه شركات
النيتو في اسيا والمحيط الهادئ التي ضمت
هذه الدول وتعرف اختصارا باي باربعه رغم
مقاومه قوى اوروبيه وعلى راسها فرنسا دعما
لخيار النيتو بمد نفوذه يشير البعض الى
قلق الصين بشكل خاص ازاء ه تبعات اتساع
اجنده النيتو على قضيه تايوان وتبدو دول
اسيويه كاليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه ايضا في
صداره القلق الصيني بسبب اتساق هذه الدول
السريع مع خطط النيتو في المنطقه وفي ظل
نزاعات حدوديه بحريه للصين مع دول عديده
ومع اطلاق واشنطن استراتيجيه متعلقه
بالصين ومبادره الشركه الاقتصاديه في
المحيطين الهندي والهادئ بدت كلها خطوات
تعيد تعريف النطاق الاستراتيجي للنيتو
الاثناء وصل مساعد وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه لشؤوني شرق اسيا والمحيط الهادئ
دانيال الى بيجين وذلك في وقت تسعى فيه
واشنطن لتعزيز التواصل مع الصين وقالت
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ان المسؤوله
سيناقش خلال زيارته القضايا الرئيسيه في
العلاقات الثنائيه
وترافق مساعد وزير الخارجيه فيها مديره
شؤون الصين وتايوان في مجلس الامن القومي
بالبيت الابيض ساره
وافادت الخارجيه بان اجتماعات المسؤول في
بيجين ستبدا الاثنين
وسيتطرق خلالها لقضايا حقوق الانسان
ومواصله الدفاع عن الحريات الاساسيه في
الصين
نقش الموضوع مع ضيفينا من بجينا الدكتور
دينغ لونج الدبلوماسي الصيني السابق
والساده العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه شنغهاي
ومن واشنطن الدكتور ماثيو كرونج المستشار
السابق في وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه ومؤلف
كتاب عوده التنافس بين القوى العظمى
في بيجين ما رساله الصين من اقتراب سفينه
حربيه لها من المدمره الامريكيه في مضيق
تايوان
هذه الحادثه يعني تعكس
مدى يعني خطوره الوضع
في
مدتها ونحيص يعني
الولايات المتحده ترسل المدمرات سفن حربيه
للتجوال بشكل يومي في هذه المياه مما يعني
تجبر الصين على الرد المناسب للتحركات
والسلوكيات
الجيش الامريكي
فاعتقل على الجانب الامريكي
يعني
يعني يبادر
بوقف مزرعه تحركات
الاستفزازيه
فلكي تدفع او ضرر في
اكثر قدوا
في
يعني يحكيك حكايات بين
القوتين الكبيرتين
دكتور ماثيو هل تدفع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بارسالها مدمرات وقطع بحريه على
هذه المنطقه الصين الى ممارسه هذه
السلوكيات في المنطقه
بالطبع لا ما يحصل هنا هو انا الصين تريد
ان تسيطر على اسيا تريد ان تكسر التحالفات
الامريكيه في اسيا تريد ان ترغي ماء
القوات الامريكيه العسكريه على الخروج من
اسيا الولايات المتحده مع اليابان وكوريا
الجنوبيه وتايوان اي حلفاءها لا تريدوا
ذلك والولايات المتحده تقوم بمراقبه
المياه الدوليه
وكذلك
الاجواء وهذا امر يتماشى مع القانون
الدولي حين تقترب الصين بطائراتها فهذا
يجعل الوضع خطيرا جدا هناك قواعد اشتباك
دوليه بالنسبه للتعامل مع هكذا اوضاع
والصين فعلا تجازف بحصول حادثه هنا
اعتقد ان هذا هو هدف الصين هي تريد ان
تزيد الوضع خطوره تريد ان تخيف الولايات
المتحده على امل ان الولايات المتحده سوف
تنسحب من اسيا لكن هذا لن يحصل
المشكله ليست فقط مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الدول التي ذكرها دكتور ماثيو
فعلا متخوفه مما تقول بانه نفوذ صيني في
المنطقه يزعزع الامن والاستقرار كيف
تتعامل بجين مع هذه الدول
اعتقد ان هذه الاطراف يعني كلها
حلفاء
للولايات المتحده فهناك اهداف مشتركه
تلك القوه
لمنع
ظهور سينك هو كبرى
عالميه فيعني
[موسيقى]
تلك الدول والاطراف تدعم
الامريكيه
لاحتواء الصين
فيعني ليس من الغريب ان هذه الدول
تحاول ايضا
يعني
تحركها الصينيه في في يعني حيوان وهي
تعتبر
مياه اقليميه
للصين
وتعتبر الصين يعني
[موسيقى]
هذا المنطقه من
سيادتها
[موسيقى]
فيترفض التدخل القوى الخارجيه في هذه
المنطقه دكتور ماثيو في المقابل تقول بجين
بان استراتيجيه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في هذه المنطقه قائمه على تخويف
جيران الصين
منها ومن انها تقوم بزعزعه الامن
والاستقرار هل لك ان توضح لنا
الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه في المحيطين
الهندي والهادئ بوجود دوله كبرى وعظمى
تتخوف منها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
مثل الصين
كنت اتمنى لو انا واشنطن لديها كل هذا
التاثير وكل هذا السلطه بحيث تتمكن من
السيطره على تايوان واليابان وكوريا
الجنوبيه لكن هذا غير صحيح هذا الدول هي
التي تخاف من الصين وتلجا الى الولايات
المتحده للمساعده
وحدها الصين يمكنها ان تحتوي الصين اصين
تصرفت في التسعينيات
بطريقه
جعلت الكثير من الدول تريد ان تتفاعل مع
الصين ولكن هذه المره اصيل تتصرف طريقه
عدائيه وبالتالي تحدث الدول من اجل التصدي
لها اذا اعتقد ان استراتيجيه الولايات
المتحده تقضي تدافع عن نفسها ضد الصين وكل
الاعداء العسكريين ليس فقط على المستوى
العسكري ولكن ايضا على مستوى انتهاكات
حقوق الانسان نحن نريد ان ندافع عن انفسنا
تجاهها او التصدي لهذا الانتهاكات وفي
الوقت نفسه نعمل على تغيير عقليه الصين
وان نقنعها بان هذه التصرفات المخيفه ليست
بمصلحتها وافضل لها ان تعتمد مقاربات اكثر
تعاونيه سريعا لو سمحت كيف يمكن ان تتعامل
بجين مع امكانيه انشاء الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
تحالف شبيه بنيتو في منطقه المحيطين
الهندي والهادئ لمواجهه نفوذ الصين كما
تقول الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
يعني
هذه جدا وحساسه
توجهها الامريكيه لتشكيل
شبح وحده
على غرار حلف الناتو في منطقه اسيا
فهي يعني
تعتزم
باتخاذ اجراءات مضاده
[موسيقى]
لكفعه
تحرق حياته ونوايا الامريكيه
لبست النفوس مع حلفائها في هذه المنطقه
بهدف
يحتوي الصين فالصين لديه كريستيانو عسكريه
كافيه وعظيمه وايرادها السياسيه قويه
لرد
توجهات الامريكيه
في تدقيق على الصين شكرا الدكتور دينغ
لونج الدبلوماسي السابق واسره العلاقات
الدوليه بجماعه شنغهاي في بيجين والدكتور
ماثيو المستشار السابق في وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه ومؤلف كتاب عوده التنافس بين
القوى العظمى في واشنطن شكرا لكما
خلال فقره في المتابعه سيكون لنا حديث
معمق وموسع حول التحذيرات الصينيه من
اقامه تحالفات عسكريه في منطقه اسيا
والمحيط الهادئ ونناقش خلفيات مخاوف
[موسيقى]
عبر الامين العام لنيتو يونس عن ترحيبه
بارسال تركيا جنودا اضافيين الى كوسوفو
لدعم الاستقرار والامني هناك واضاف خلال
زيارته لاسطنبول ان الحلفا بصدد ارسال نحو
700 جندي اضافي من الحلف الى هناك يذكر ان
القوات النيتو في كوسوفو المعروفه باسم
تعمل على حفظ السلام في كوسوفو منذ سيف
عام 1999
التوترات الاخيره في كوسوفو تعيد تسليط
الضوء على قوات النيتو الموجوده في ذلك
البلد الاوروبي الغالبيه المسلمه
قبل ايام اصيب عشرات من قوات النيتو في
كوسوفو والمعروفه باسم خلال مواجهات مع
مواطنين من العرقيه الصربيه شمال البلاد
الذين تدعمهم بالجراد اثارت صور مصابي
قوات كي 4 حفيظه دول الناتو التي سرعان ما
قررت ارسال 700 مقاتل لتعزيز وجود الحلف
الساعي لحفظ الامن في البلاد ساهمت في
التعزيزات الجديده قوات تركيه تقدر
بخمسمائه من الكوماندوز طارت نحو كوسوفو
ونشرت وزاره الدفاع التركيه صورا لها
مساهمه استدعت امتنانا وشكرا من النيتو
لتركيا خلال زياره امين عام الحلف
لاسطنبول انا
ارحب بقرار تركيا ارسال جنود اضافيين لدعم
القوات الدوليه في كوسوفو وسنرسل الان نحو
700 جندي من الحلف وتركيا ستقود الجهود
الدوليه لارسال هذه القوات كي فور او قوات
كوسوفو ارسلها النيتو الى هناك صيفه عام
استنادا لقرار مجلس الامن
1244 وذلك بعيدا انتهاء حمله الحلف الجويه
ضد النظام سلوبو
دانميت 78 يوما دفاعا عن رغبه البان
كوسوفو المسلمين في الاستقلال عن صربيا
وريثه نيوزلافيا السابقه التي تفككت قبلها
بسنوات في البدايه تالفت قوات النيتو
بيكوسوفو من 50 الف جندي اخذت في التناقص
بناء على تراجع التوتر في البلاد وانتشار
الامن حتى بلغت حاليا نحو اربعه الاف
مقاتل وفق الموقع الرسمي لقوات النيتو في
كوسوفو فان مهمتها تهدف اصلا الى ردع تجدد
الاعمال العدائيه وتهيئه بيئه امنه وضمان
السلامه العامه والنظام وتجريد ما يسمى
بجيش تحرير كوسوفو من السلاح ودعم الجهد
الانساني الدولي والتنسيق مع الوجود
المدني الدولي تندلع الموجه الاخيره من
التوتر في كوسوفو على واقع استقطاب عسكري
دولي حاد ينخرط بفعل تداعيات الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا
اليوم في كوسوفو تجد نفسها في مواجهه خصم
شديد التماهي مع موسكو لدرجه اقدام عناصر
من صرب كوسوفو خلال الاشتباكات الاخيره
على رسم حرف زد على مركبات الناتو في
اشاره للشعار الروسي خلال حرب اوكرانيا
موقفا رافضا لاستقلال كوسوفو المعلن عام
2008 ونقل قبل ايام عن سيرجي لافروف وزير
الخارجيه الروسي ان الصربه في شمال كوسوفو
يقاتلون من اجل حقوقهم محذرا في نفس
السياق مما وصفه بانفجار كبير يلوح في قلب
اوروبا
[موسيقى]
جانبه قال قائد القوات الدوليه لحفظ
السلام التي يقودها النيتو ان مهمه الحلف
لا ينبغي اعتبارها مظله يعثر فيها على
ملجا بعد الاجراءات الاحاديه الجانب التي
تخل بالتوازنات غير المستقره وقال قائد
القوه ان شمالي كوسوفو بدون مهمه سيكون
بؤره اخرى للحرب كما اتهم القائد العسكري
رئيس حكومه كوسوفو البينكورتي باتخاذ
اجراءات احاديه الجانب قائلا انه ارسل
رؤساء البلديه الجدد الى منشات البلديه
دون مراعاه نصيحه المجتمع الدولي وان شرطه
كوسوفو استخدمت القوه دون استشاره قوه
الناتو وقال قائد قوه حفظ السلام ان
التدخل الناتو في الشمال احدث تاثيرا قصير
المدى داعيا الى استغلال النافذه الزمنيه
لبدء مفاوضات حقيقيه بين كوسوفو وصربيا
[موسيقى]
اعلنت مجموعه اوبيك بلس عزم الدول
المشاركين فيها على تخفيض مستوى الانتاج
المستهدف للعام القادم بواقع مليون و400
الف برميل يوميا وبحسب البيان فان اوبك
بلس اتفقت على ضبط المستوى الاجمالي
لانتاج النفط الخام الى 40 مليون و460 الف
برميل يوميا وذلك اعتبارا من الاول من
يناير 2024 وحتى نهايته في حين اعلنت كل
من روسيا والسعوديه والكويت وسلطنه عمان
والامارات والعراق والجزائر عن تمديد
التخفيضات الطوعيه للانتاج الخاص بها حتى
نهايه العام 2024 ما يعني ان التخفيضات
الاجماليه ستصل الى اكثر من اربعه ملايين
برميل يوميا
وقال وزير الطاقه السعوديه الامير عبد
العزيز بن سلمان ال سعود ان الاتفاق الذي
توصلت اليه مجموعه اوبك بلس غير مسبوق وفي
مؤتمر صحفي مشترك مع عدد وزراء الطاقه في
مقر اوبك في فيينا اضاف الوزير السعودي ان
قرار اليوم يساعد على تعزيز فرص استقرار
الاسواق ومنع التذبذب الحاد
نحن الان امام اتفاق غير مسبوق اذ عدنا
الى الخلف وطرحنا السؤال الصعب كيف يمكن
لنا ان نتوصل الى اتفاق يوفر رؤيه اوضح
للسوق واكثر شفافيه وانصافا وحتى مستقله
عن قراءاتنا ومطالباتنا بغض النظر عن
طبيعه تلك المطالبات ولذلك تم اعتماد هذا
الاتفاق بنسبه مئه في المئه وهذا يحدث
لاول مره
انضم الينا من لندن الدكتور مصطفى
البزركان الخبير في شؤون النفط والطاقه
دكتور ما الذي استدعى هذا الاتفاق من
طبعا بدايه هناك ما يتعلق كان بالمعروف
وهناك بالطلب كان هناك
مفرد في المعروض ولذلك تراجعت الاسعار في
مرت في الفترات خلال الاسابيع الماضيه الى
دون السبعين دولار هذا لا يتوالم مع توازن
السوق من ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى كان هناك
تاثيرات بسبب هناك بعض الاقتصادات دخلت
مرحله ركودك الاقتصاد الالماني الاقتصادي
البريطاني هناك مشاكل في التضخم هذه
جميعها دعت منظمه اوبك الى التوصل الى
اتفاق هذا الاتفاق تاريخي لماذا لان هناك
اولا اتفاق استراتيجي بمعنى انه الدول
المنتجه والدول المستهلكه تعرف ماذا سيحصل
في الاسواق من خلال المعروض ومن خلال
الطلب هذه نقطه النقطه الثانيه هذا القرار
هو قرار بالاجماع بمعنى كان مرضيا
وملائما لجميع الاعضاء ولذلك كان هناك
هذه هذه المفاجاه نصحه التعبير لم يكن احد
يتوقع هذا الاتفاق بهذه التفاصيل
الاستراتيجيه هذا الذي يجعل هذا الاتفاق
هو له اهميه
هل ممكن ان هناك هذا الاتفاق على زياده في
الطلب مستقبلا
يعتمد على على الطلب يعني دعني اوضح نقطه
انه الكل يؤشر الى انه هناك
لن يتحقق النمو الاقتصادي في الصين ولكن
الصين يعني مستمره في الطلب على النفط
واستيراد النفط لانه هناك يتوفر النفط
الروسي المخفف في الاسواق روسيا تصدر اكثر
من اربعه مليون برميل بتخفيضات تصل الى 30
دولار للبرميل رغم انه هذا هذه ليست
منافسه عادله مع المنتجين الاخرين ولكن تم
الاتفاق كان هناك تاكيد انه روسيا ملتزمه
بخفض الانتاج 500 الف برميل
طوعيا كما هي الدول الاخرى هناك نقطه مهمه
انه المملكه العربيه السعوديه اقرت وقررت
خفض انتاج اضافي لمليون برميل خلال الشهر
القادم هذه نقطه مهمه وقد يكون هناك حاجه
لتمديد هذا الخفض هذا يعني انه منظمه اوبك
تراقب الاسواق عن كثب وتبحث عن توازن هذه
الاسواق بين مصلحه المنتجين ومصلحه
المستهلكين دكتور المحتمله لهذا القرار
على الدول الاكثر استهلاكا مثل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه مثلا التي هي رافضه
اساسا
لعمليه تخفيض الانتاج
صحيح رافضه ولكنها في ذات الوقت سحبت من
المخزون الاستراتيجي ولم تعد ملئه هذه
نقطه النقطه الثانيه لابد من ذكرها انه في
اتفاق
سقف الديون الامريكيه قبل يوم اعتمد
الاتفاق عليه من ضمن الاتفاقات هو زياده
انتاج شركات النفط ونشاط هذا هذا يدل على
انه هناك ايضا
جهود امريكيه لزياده الانتاج هذه جميعها
ان تحقق وقفزت اسعار النفط المهم هي ليست
الوصول الى سعر معين يعني يوم غد قد يكون
هناك زياده بثلاثه الى اربعه بالمئه واكثر
ولكن العبره باستمرار في هذا المستوى معين
على المدى الاستراتيجي لابد من وصول اسعار
النفط الى اعلى من هذه الاسعار لماذا لانه
قطاع النفطي يحتاج الى استثمارات الدول
المنتجه للنفط ليس لديها الموارد الكافيه
لزياده الاستثمارات وبالتالي سيكون هناك
نقص بعيد للمداخل لسنوات القادمه شكرا
الدكتور مصطفى البزر كان الخبير في شؤون
النفط والطاقه في لندن
اعلن حزباء القوات اللبنانيه والكتائب
وكتل برلمانيه ونواب مستقلون عن ترشيح
الوزير السابق جهاد ازعور لرئاسه
الجمهوريه لبنانيه وفي ختام لقاء جمع
ممثلين عن هذه القوى اعلن المرشح للرئاسه
اللبنانيه ميشال معوض انسحابه لصالح جهاد
ازعور كما اكد المجتمعون توافقهم مع
التيار الوطني الحر برئاسه جبران باسيل
على ترشيح ازعور مشيرين الى انه شخصيه
وسطيه غير استفزازيه
نقل موقع
عن المتحدث باسم الاسطول الامريكيه الخامس
والقوات البحريه المشتركه تيم هوكنز قوله
ان التحالف البحري الذي اعلنت ايران
تشكيله مع السعوديه ودول خليجيه اخرى امر
غير منطقي ويتحدى العقل واضاف ان ايران هي
المسؤول الاول عن عدم الاستقرار الاقليمي
وتريد تشكيله تحالف امني بحري لحمايه
المياه التي تهددها جاءت تصريحات المسؤوله
العسكري الامريكي ردا على قائد البحريه
الايرانيه الاميرال شهرام ايراني الذي قال
ان بلاده ستشكل تحالفات جديده تشمل القوات
البحريه لايران ودول عده واشار المسؤول
الايراني الى ان بلاده ستتعاون مع
السعوديه والهند والامارات وقطر والبحرين
والعراق وباكستان في اطار هذا التحالف
ما تزال اسرائيل تعيش تحت تاثير العمليه
العسكريه التي وقعت فجر السبت عند الحدود
مع مصر وفي وقت تحقق فيه اسرائيل بما تصفه
اختراقا امنيا كبيرا يطرحوا الهجوم اسئله
بشان اداء الجنود الاسرائيليين ودوافع
المنفذ فضلا عن التفاعل الشعبي العربي
الواسع المؤيد العمليه مقابل محاولات
ترويج التطبيع
اسرائيل في صدمه ثلاثيه حجم الخسائر صدمه
واسلوب العمليه صدمه ومصدرها صدمه فقط
لاها ثلاثه جنود وجريحان احدهما ضابط
والموقع عند الحدود مع مصر والمنفذ مصري
برصاص مصريه حقائق كانت كفيله بتحويل
الامر في اسرائيل الى عاصفه من الاسئله
والغضب لم تبددها روايات تضاربت بين جيشها
الذي نشر صور قتلاه على يد من وصفه بمخرب
مصري وهي مفرده تلازم في العاده حديثه عن
الفدائيين والمقاومين وبين روايه الجيش
المصري التي تحدثت عن مطارده فرد امن
لمهرب مخدرات عند الحدود دون اتضاح مصير
المهربين وما الذي اوقع الجنود
الاسرائيليين في الوسط ليقتلوا على
مرحلتين ظل خلالها العسكري المصري مترصدا
لساعات قبل ان يقتل لا صوره للان ولا اسما
للمنفذ الذي تحول الى ايقونه شعبيه مجهوله
لا معلومات قاطعه غير توافق على تحقيقات
ثنائيه بدات فيها اسرائيل واضبه وللغضب
تفسيره لقد ضربت اسرائيل من حيث لم تحتسب
وما جرى حادثا كان او هجوما انما يكشف لما
يراقب عن خيبه مقيمه فان كان وراءه سبب
فكري حركه عداء راسخ لاسرائيل التي خاضت
معهم مصر حروبا سالت فيها دماء فانه خوف
لا حل له وان كان ملاحقه في واجب امني
فنتيجته واحده وهي ان رجلا مسلحا ببندقيه
قديمه تفوق على مجموعه مما يوصف بالجيش
الذي لا يقهر وفي ذلك ما فيه من هشاشه
الاداء العسك ري لجنود الاحتلال حين
يتجردون من طائراتهم ودباباتهم
على الحدود على ان اهم ما تركبه اسرائيل
بعين السياسه هو الاحتفاء الشعبي الجارف
بما صار يوصف عربيا بالبطل الشهيد بما
يكسر رهانها على تبدل المزاج الشعبي
العربي تجاهها رغم قاطره التطبيع الرسمي
التي تصطدم عند اول منعطف بوجدان جمعي
رافض كثير من التفاصيل لم تكشف بعد ولا
يعرف اين ستصل التحقيقات والمتابعات لكن
ما يبدو يقينا انه بالرغم من السنوات
والاتفاقات تكتشف اسرائيل وغيرها انما في
القلب في القلب
[موسيقى]
عوده الى موضوع التحذيرات الصينيه من
اقامه تحالفات عسكريه في منطقه اسيا
والمحيط الهادئ ثم خاوف بتجين تثيرها
تحالفات قائمه بالفعل منها القديم ومنها
المستجد اهمها مجموعه اوكوس وهي تحالف
ثلاثي تاسس في سبتمبر 2021 يضم الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا واستراليا هدفه تعزيز
الوجود العسكري الغربي في منطقه المحيطين
الهندي والهادئ ويغطي تحالف اكوس مجالات
الذكاء الاصطناعي والحرب الالكترونيه
وقدرات الضربه بعيده المدى وبمقتضى
الاتفاقيه تحصل استراليا على غواصات تعمل
بالطاقه النوويه من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ومن بريطانيا تمت ايضا التحالف
الامني الرباعي كواد الذي انشئ عام 2007
بين الولايات المتحده واليابان واستراليا
والهند وارتبط التحالف باجراء مناوره
عسكريه مشتركه
مناورات ماليبر واثارت غضب الصين الشديد
وكان التحالف الرباعي يخطط لانشاء ما يسمى
القوس الديمقراطي الاسيوي بانضمام معظم
البلدان الواقعه على حدود الصين اليه في
اسيا الوسطى ومنغوليا وشبه جزيره الكوريه
ودول اخرى في جنوب شرق اسيا تضاف تلك
التكتلات الى التحالفات التاريخيه التي
عقدتها الولايات المتحده بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه لا سيما مع اليابان
وكوريا الجنوبيه وايضا مع الفلبين اقامه
تلك التحالفات غالبا ما تتوج باجراء
مناوره عسكريه في شرق اسيا تعتبرها الصين
استفزازا لها وتسميها دبلوماسيه الزوارق
الحربيه ففي ابريل الماضي اجلت الولايات
المتحده والفلبين على مدى اسبوعين اكبر
مناورات عسكريه مشتركه بينهما على الاطلاق
وكانت المناورات محاكاه لهجوم على سفينه
حربيه في بحر جنوب الصيني في اغسطس من
العام الماضي شهدت المنطقه واحده من اضخم
المناورات المشتركه بين الجيشين الامريكي
والكوري الجنوبي في ظل توتر متصاعد مع
الصين قبل ذلك بثلاث سنوات اجرت الولايات
المتحده وعشر دول تشكل رابطه اسيان
تدريبات عسكريه مشتركه جوا وبحرا امتدت من
المياه الدوليه في جنوب شرق اسيا الى
خليجي تايلاند وبحري جنوب الصين وحتى
سنغافوره المزيد ينضم الينا من عفوا
الدكتور ادوارد هاويل وهو استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه المختص بشؤون شرق اسيا بجامعه
مرحبا بكم ما امكانيه تشكيل تحالف بقياده
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في منطقه شرق
اسيا في ظل الظروف والتوترات القائمه
سوف نراه وفي احتمال كبير ان يحصل بنظر
الى الادله التي رايناها هو ان يكون هناك
تحالفات ثنائيه بين الولايات المتحده وكل
من كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان
وتتعزز لقد سبق لنا ان راينا ان كوريا
الجنوبيه واليابان واجهات المتحده تعهدت
بانها سوف ترتقي بمستوى التعاون بعد تعززه
بالنسبه الى منظمه دفاعيه اقليميه
وما يشبه حلف شمال الاطلسي في اسيا لا
اعتقد ان هذا سوف يحصل بالنظر الى التركيز
على التحالفات الثنائيه وتاريخ هذا
التحالفات الثنائيه
بالرغم من ذلك السؤال المطروح هو الى اي
مدى هذه التحالفات الثنائيه الامريكيه مع
عدد من الدول وعلاقات تلك الدول بين بعضها
من شانها فعلا ان تساعد في الحد والتخفيف
من مخاطر الصين وكذلك كوريا الشماليه
النوويه امام سباق التحالفات في هذه
المنطقه دكتور وسباق الصين
فيما يتعلق بقضيه تايوان ما هو السيناريو
المتوقع اذا
اعتقد ان السيناريو غير المتوقع على المدى
القصير او المتوقع بالاحرى هو ان العلاقات
بين الصين والولايات المتحده سوف تستمر
بان تكون
بارده
الجليديه لقد راينا هذا النقد اللاذع
لوزير الدفاع الصيني من قبل الولايات
المتحده وهذا لا يشير لها اي شيء جديد بل
يظهروا اسمرار الصين بيسياساتها هذا يعني
ان التباينات بين الدولتين سوف لن ثم
سريعا فان لم تحصل الصين على ما تريد في
هذه المنطقه سوف لن تكون مستعده
لطاعه الولايات المتحده
والامتثال لما تريده الولايات المتحده
وهنا سال عن الصين كيف يمكن ان يكون رد
فعلها على توسيع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تحالفاتها في منطقه تعتبرها
منطقه نفوذها
على الارجح سوف لن نرى استمرارا في
التفاعلات الصينيه
[موسيقى]
سوف نرى استمرارا في هذه التفاعلات
الصينيه من حيث نشر المزيد من
نشر القوات وكذلك استمرارها في لعب دور
في محاوله تغيير النظام العالمي لاسيما من
خلال مبادرات طريق
الحرير وغيرها ان انتقادها للنظام الذي
تقوده الولايات المتحده يبدو انه سوف
يستمر لاسيما الان مع هذه الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا شكرا لك الدكتور ادوارد هاول
الاستاذ العلاقات الدوليه المختص بشؤون
شرق اسيا بجامعه اوكسفورد شكرا
اذا بهذا ننهي الحصاد هذه الليله شكرا لكم
على حسن المتابعه الى اللقاء بامان الله
ورعايته
[موسيقى]